more we're joined by dr amish adulja
senior scholar at the johns hopkins
center for health security he's in
pittsburgh this morning
doctor good morning to you cases spiking
enormously in some spots including here
in new york city how concerned are you
right now
i'm concerned as we move into this
winter season with both delta and
omicron together and this swath of the
population that is not vaccinated that
we are going to see high-risk people get
infected and then require
hospitalization and hospitals in many
parts of the country are already
struggling because there are so many
delta patients that are unvaccinated
that are taking up beds and this is
going to add to it and omicron is going
to probably speed that process that was
inevitably going to occur along even
faster and it may be too much for some
hospitals to handle
dr some people a lot of people talk
about they're cancelling events
people parents talking about pulling
kids out of school next week because of
this huge uptick in some spots is that
too much
it all depends upon the the context and
situation you have to realize that this
virus isn't going anywhere and i think
all of us are going to get omicron at
some point in time because this is just
such a highly transmissible virus and
it's going to establish itself in the
human population
i think if you're in a situation where
cases are so so high that they're
disruptive that you can't actually
convene some kind of meeting or convene
school that's one thing but we do have
tools we're not completely helpless we
have testing we have masks we have
vaccinations we have monoclonal
antibodies and we're going to soon have
antivirals so i don't think that we have
to kind of set back the clock to the
beginning of the pandemic but i think
people have to be careful about the fact
that this is going to be a disruptive
force in the coming weeks
are we seeing these huge spikes because
we have two variants out there
the larger part of the spike is caused
by delta delta is still the dominant
version of the virus that's out there
but omicron is starting to cause spikes
at least regionally so for example in
new york city we saw the the outbreak on
cornell university's campus that that's
a lot to do with omicron but we still
are kind of bathed in a lot of delta
eventually it's going to be all omicron
but it's right now delta plus omicron
causing this major problem and what's in
the hospitals is primarily delta right
now two things dr adelga first you just
said that we'll see antivirals soon do
we have a timeline on that
not completely we know that pfizer has
submitted for emergency use
authorization and their antiviral is the
more promising one when compared to the
merc version and so this is something
that the fda needs to move expeditiously
on because right now we could be using
this antiviral we've seen the data it's
safe and effective i think it meets the
criteria for an emergency use
authorization and that antiviral is
something you take by mouth and has a 90
chance of keeping you out of the
hospital keeping you from dying it's
very very uh path breaking and i think
it's part of what we need in our toolbox
as we face this new variant
the other thing that i'm thinking
because this is the conversation we had
here this morning so many people are
when do we get to the point where we do
start treating this like the flu because
of things as you mentioned like the
antivirals but also because many are
vaccinated right now and boosted
to me to me that transition occurs when
we're not worried about hospital
capacity and i think in many parts of
the country we we have
successfully kind of decoupled cases
from hospitalizations in a way that we
hadn't in the past but there are many
parts of the country where there are too
many unvaccinated individuals those with
high risk conditions where a hospital
has to work worry about capacity on a
day-to-day basis to me that's the
transition point and i think we'll get
there and we will get there during 2022
and the antiviral is part of that but
it's going to be kind of a patchwork of
where we get there because the way the
unvaccinated or distributed around the
country puts a lot of hospitals
basically holds them hostage because
they could get hit hard with a wave and
then that lead to hospitalizations
doctor i heard one well-regarded expert
yesterday say because omicron is so
transmissible that the surge or the
level of concern with omicron is going
to last a matter of weeks whereas delta
was months is that right
it's hard it's hard to know that so when
you look at the data from south africa
which was the first country to get hit
hard by the omicron variant they've
already seen cases fall so there may be
something unique about the epidemiology
with delta it was two weeks we saw these
two month searches where maybe 20 of the
people that were susceptible got
infected all of a sudden and then this
and then there was no no one knew to
infect because people changed their
behavior that may not be the same the
same and this may be quicker this may be
longer i think we still don't have
enough data to be able to say for sure
but we know one thing we know for sure
is that it is coming
dr adalja always still so many what-ifs
out there but we appreciate the insight
thank you
thank